[Music]
hello and welcome to the greatest movie
ever podcast where we dissect our guests
favorite film in all that silver screen
cinematic scope this week I'm joined by
fellow podcaster and host of watching
The Watchmen in which me and him we
analyze the graphic novel The Watchmen
we've just finished the book so make
sure you go and check that out he also
hosts a podcast called battle rap resume
and alphabet allah khair the former
which interviews battle rappers from
around the world and the latter which
works through Metallica's back catalogue
he's a great guy with a lovely sounding
voice Tom how's it going yes hello hello
is is great to be on here I know I love
your work not least the ones that I
guest on and also when you explain the
ending of I'm pretty sure one on your
channel and you expose for out of there
and you've done like an ending explained
and I recognize the fun now because it
was some shitty Netflix film my
girlfriend watch the other day about
some like some fat girl pretending to be
a thin girl that's it I mean yeah maybe
one day somewhere lenio in the future
we'll do a podcast like this encierro
bird shall be their film I don't even
want it but it was bad it was bad i
watch you a lot of [ __ ] movies Tom yeah
sure you've seen my ending explain video
so pretty well at the moment I'm just
trying to do every single movie that
comes out to just throw as much at the
wall and see which sticks and some of
them do really well but then you've got
like selfie from Hell which I thought
would do well but it's on about 400
views yeah so go listen to that one
listeners don't watch the movie just
listen to her anyway but how Tom does it
feel to be on the other end of the mic
for once it's it's unusual yeah I want
to take command I want to stop reeling
off Twitter's etc no I'm happy to be on
the other end sometimes no in cinema
it's good to be the audience member it's
good to receive I guess sometimes
definitely in cinema cuz would probably
be [ __ ] doing a direct in a movie too
we're doing podcasts together so I can't
imagine what a movie would be like
anyway today the film that we're going
to be discussing is 12 Angry Men mmm
when I first started kind of organizing
this podcast I messaged about 30 people
and who all wanted to be on the show I
was like what's your favorite movie and
I've kind of tried to structure the
order of the podcast in sort of differ
in a different genre every every episode
and 12 Angry Men it's actually the only
film on the list that I've never
actually seen right until till now which
was a weird one for me because obviously
I watch a lot of films and it's also one
that's often listed as one of the
greatest films ever made
um pretty much most lists so when did
you first become aware of the film yeah
it was through the list that I became
aware of it so I've always really been
into and Stealer into like dialogue
heavy movies bottle movies things that
are in one place like dinner for Andre
or the before sunset before sunrise that
Julia Delfy even Hawke trilogy and
boiler room you know with Ben Affleck
and those sort movies so I always
enjoyed those sort of movies and I
remember going on IMDB diehard dot yet
diehard exactly Monsters Inc and yeah
and I remember going onto the top 250
and pretty much knowing all the films
I've got in front of me now and if you
read so this is the top 10 so it's Fight
Club good the bad knee okay Pulp Fiction
Return of the King Schindler's List 12
Angry Men and then we have Dark Knight
Godfather one and two and Shawshank and
12 Angry Men
does stick out as a sore thumb there I
had never heard it before I remember
seeing it in 2009 and that was back when
I used to work at McDonald's and I
became friends with Nathaniel's now it's
still one of my great friends huge movie
guy and I remember us to just bugging
out over this movie I watched it and I
was just yeah we're just floored by it
really I'm watching it back in the last
few days I still regard it highly I
don't know if it's like my favorite film
ever but it's dead I know if I have a
favorite film but it's definitely wonder
you know I enjoy a hell of a lot so yeah
watching about oh nine
gradually you know BRE watching it
through the years like my my electrician
chav brother I remember showing him this
film a few years ago where on a holiday
even he liked it deaf I think it's one
of those films like that cuts through
and the quality is quite evident yeah
definitely and it's of it it wasn't
originally a film and had quite a lot of
success before getting adapted it is
actually a play and it basically the
movie of this story is it's it's a jury
made up of 12 men and they're
deliberating the conviction or acquittal
of a defendant based on the basis of
reasonable doubt which it kind of forces
the jurors to question their own morals
and values and and is it's a very
thought-provoking there's not really a
right or wrong answer there's outside of
the room we don't get much development
in terms of the the crime itself or the
the person who's being persecuted for it
or even the victims and but it's still
regarded really highly and why do you
think this has had such a legacy to it
for me it's the it's the purity of the
thing it's the story wise you can poke
some holes in it and some of the logic
that will get into that they go through
I found myself being a little spurious
at it actually and I think I said you
before we did the episode there's quite
a few articles out there that are
convinced that they let her they let her
guilty man go free essentially it
doesn't really add up for me it's the
acting that's what I've always enjoyed
with cinema and you know moving back
I like seeing all these twelve guys play
each other I like the ratchet intention
and I like bottle cinema are like things
that take place in literally one room I
mean you could argue they go to the
bathroom as well at points and you know
we see them when they're sitting on the
this or the bench and the steps at the
beginning in the end but yeah you know
if I think I think the legacy the reason
why it shines for the reason why any of
these old films shine through is twofold
it's both the charm you know that this
is from 1957 you know 60 odd years old
but it's still so shining so bright so
effective but the themes
you know it just makes you quite quite
skeptical you know in quite questioning
and I think that all of us in this round
even though we haven't been watching the
case over six or seven days or a long
they've been in there we just get the
play-by-play you pretty much are
convinced that he's guilty from the off
and fonder is working against you you
are the dough in his hands and it's just
quite an enjoyable experience really
even when I'm reaching it you're
measuring up and you're keeping tabs on
what people think and who they are and
where they turn guilty or not guilty
like one of the things I didn't even
realize when I rewatched the other day
was the the ad man the Don Draper like
figure who's not very focused
he actually swears he actually switched
his verdict it's quite a few times he
goes guilty not guilty guilty not guilty
and I don't I I like the scorekeeping
aspect of it and I just think all the
performances across the board are
fantastic I guess you could argue that
the the villain of the piece the guy
rips up the photo of his son at the end
Lee Jay Cobb you know he's a huge actor
in his time he was in on the on the
waterfront he was the guy who originally
played Willy Loman in the original
Broadway staging of Death of a Salesman
I think I think all of the actors are
excellent in our just like seeing them
work yeah definitely in the film itself
it's really well shot and put together
especially for the time I did I watched
on blu-ray upscale to 4k surprisingly
Tom not a good transfer no but we'll let
them off I had just watched the revenant
and 4k before it but we'll let them off
with that unless it let's just get in in
the film itself and we'll kind of talked
about the background of it but it opens
on a courtroom which is one of the only
scenes that takes place outside of the
jurors room and we pan across the
characters and it's sort of a great
opener that slowly introduces you to
what I'll call the 12 angry white men
yeah or the gamin as it would be numb
today I guess as a foreigner in the mix
though they don't but yeah yeah so which
which one of so which one's the
foreigner because I took them all is I
know there's a guy who says he's from
the slums yeah
the watchmaker that I believe he's meant
to be Italian and that gets brought up
the my favorite character the bellezza
the bullet yeah
the belligerent baseball fan sort of
mocks him for it or head who has some of
the best weapons in the movie I just
love that guy straight out of the
fifties but yeah I'm loved love the
courtroom scare steps the the grand
imposing edifice
I love the tracking shot as well because
there's a lot of sort of cinematography
going on throughout obviously it's kind
of like six form analysis how we get
closer as the film goes on and you know
we get loads of Kosovo but I like how we
see the life outside the courtroom I
like how we see a case that has gone
well where a husband and wife read
bracing in tears overjoyed and then we
move over to the window and I like how
we see the accused who's kind of this
blanket that we can imprint ourselves on
to like he kind of looks Jewish she kind
of looks Turkish I mean it's made up a
lot there's a lot of racism in this room
was a lot of prejudice from the Duras
yeah I do really like it and they kind
of he's in in the film for very little
but yeah did leave quite a lasting
impression on me and there's a lot going
on in his face he looks really fearful
he does he looked really scared for his
life but then you kind of looking at him
thinking is that guilt or is it because
he's got caught um and he just knows
that his life is in their hands and they
reached the room and they all kind of
slowly sit down and it looks like it's a
pretty open-and-shut case everyone's
made the mind up from from the looks of
it and then Fonda he sticks his bloody
nose in it and he just kind of derails
it all it would have been great if it
had had just been like a ten minute
movie where they all just go in and
decide that he's guilty but fun he was
fun messing around font finders that
thunders the goanna and I want to point
to as well anyone who wants another 12
Angry Men stole film with Fonda in it
there's a great western called the Oxbow
incident which is pretty much twelve
Angry Men as a West and it's set in a
saloon where the debating whether to
hang a man and it's a very good film as
well and
Cowboys is great the music as well by
Kenyan Hopkins very subtle but I love
the theme I love that delicate string
theme Mary pensive yeah definitely and
there's another little nice touch in
there Tom they walk into the room and
one of the guys looks at all
and they go I never one of them Remember
Who it's this lights Aslam guy yeah
right okay he goes I never knew they
locked the door which kind of shows that
they feel a bit trapped in the situation
either trapped in this room and the
characters that don't even really go to
the verdict straightaway they all kind
of chat to themselves and it shows their
hands almost in advance and what way
they're kind of gonna go in the film
some are even excited at the fact that
they're going to be sending a man to his
death yeah and there's a real detachment
from it and it really reminded me of
something that I studied in university
and which is something that's called
distance killing that was really brought
to life under the like the Nazis that
the Nazis basically did psychological
studies where they learned that firing
squads could often be traumatizing for
the shooter and which is then where they
started using blanks and some of the
rifles so that some people could kind of
walk away and believe that they weren't
the killer they you know they were just
there and then the Nazis really took it
to the next level and with poisoning so
a soldier in in the concentration camp
would stand on top of a roof and simply
just tip a lever to kill hundreds of
people at a time and they didn't call
them soldiers they called them
sanitation officers to kind of get away
from thinking that they were murderers
and this sort of ease and murder is what
I'm kind of reminded about when I see
how gleeful and that most of the people
in this room are about just killing a
man because they know they're not gonna
have to get the hands to see they're not
gonna have to participate in it they
just have to decide whether someone dies
or not and its distance killing and for
me and it's great to see this sort of
dark personalities that we have in this
room taking joy from wanting to murder
someone
yeah one of them says lucky to get a
murder case you know you're right they
all right they're enjoying the prospect
and you know some of the best early
lines offer I'm just gonna call it
baseball guy when when the other old man
villain not necessarily Leigh Jacobs
figure the one who everyone turns to hit
back on at the end when he's horrific ly
racist when he like what he blows his
nose and he's like the horn works now
try the lights it's like I want to get
that into conversation I wanna start say
no one anyone sneezes around me yeah but
but and I think the development of all
of the characters is expert yes 12
characters in this room that's hard to
get across and I would argue pretty much
all of them are individual the only one
who maybe isn't that individual is the
kind of tough guy who stands up for the
old man I don't think he's as long as
well but they're all interesting yeah
definitely and they all kind of leave
their mark in some way and I quite like
when they start deliberating that you
even fonder he doesn't really say that
he's not guilty he just says that he
doesn't know and he thinks there's a
doubt which this whole movie sort of
based around the the us verdict of you
know beyond it has to be beyond a
reasonable doubt which I don't think
it's that common in this country and but
basically the US justice system believes
that if crimes seems to beyond a
reasonable doubt that the person could
have perpetrated it then you shouldn't
say that they're guilty and but fonda
just says he doesn't know which plays
into that and he starts them off by just
saying look we'll have an hour debate um
and if by that we can't decide then I'll
let you just go home early he doesn't
say that but you know he acts there and
symbolically he wears white and I think
throughout this film he sort of the
angelic character of this piece he's
sort of the angel on everyone's shoulder
that stops them from giving in to their
darkest desires yeah and do we get the
switchblade invoked I mean it's okay
it's like it's a play pretty much for
all the props that we get take an hour
just taking place in this one room and
it could be boring if not for the you
know the vivid nature of the script
just think it moves along at a great
pace than 90 minutes like it's you know
it's not that cinematic really of a film
like you know as mentioned like before
sunrise before something or just might
be a little bit of clerks
kind of anti cinema you know just sort
of dwelling in these locations although
there is an artistry but behind the
camera I was actually reading about
Sidney Lumet who's basically saying you
know the director who's incredible
director you know did like Serpico Dog
Day Afternoon he did a really good film
with Philip Seymour Hoffman before the
devil knows you're dead I think that was
his last film in the early 2000 and he's
he said quote I shot the first third of
the movie above eye-level shot the
second third at eye level and the last
third from below eye level in that way
towards the end the ceiling began to
appear not only were the walls closing
in the ceiling was as well the sense of
increasing cost her phobia did a lot to
raise attention for the last part of the
movie in the film's last shot he
observed used a wide-angle lens to let
us finally breathe and you know I guess
with a film like this less so we've say
you know he did alien beforehand we kind
of have to go what we did on Watchmen
here and sort of recount the plot
because it's such a you know a linear
film in that way but you know I just
loved the dialogue I love the way mooks
walks through and he is a bit of a white
knight fonder but never to any
irritating extent I think it's just it's
healthy the level of skepticism he's
exhibiting yeah definitely and you kind
of do get that feeling that his debate
is healthy especially when we go around
the room and everyone gives their
reasons and it's also based on
prejudices and guesses and the witness
is the one thing that this case really
hinges on like and what I do like about
is every character is so consistent
throughout they all sort of stick to
their guns for quite a while and which
really makes you feel like Fonda has a
struggle ahead of him and no one really
does anything out of place throughout
the movie everything ramps up but it all
feels natural in its progression and
it's a real testament to the writing how
well the characters become develop
because you know often in movies if a
character does something drastic or
drastically changes their mind in
in the opposite direction it can be a
bit jarring but here it just feels
completely natural throughout the entire
film and it's just really well-written
yeah it is I love how they're all
developed as they go through and there's
lots of sort of tactile things in the
film a lot of the evidence that they
talk about you know unlike hell when
they get into this thing about the old
man taking the steps and they measure
and then the camera goes down low behind
Fonda's four and they're all debate and
they're all arguing and look there's
never any time where the characters are
necessarily silent like whenever they
bring up a good point there's always two
or three to say what the [ __ ] what does
that mean what does that matter you know
what I mean like I don't agree with you
there's always a you know a solid
roadblock that I really appreciate and
lots of nice twists as well like you
know there's a bit where need to wait
you know no one could be that sure in
fact what keep it exactly you know and
when they're talking about I'm gonna
kill you and then the villain says you
have bomb there it's like ah you know I
love those sort of twists as well that
go through and we get so many close-ups
we get so many just character face on
screen and I I just love it I think the
way they staged is fantastic and they've
all got very classic like 1957 faces
yeah definitely and they've sort of its
cost you really well as well and
throughout the film as the room gets
hotter the sweat patches start to appear
and people start to like undress in
their clothes and it also heightens up
how stressed out that they are and
throughout just by having their their
clothes changed very subtly but it's
just really that the level of detail and
the consistency that's kept through is
as absolutely brilliant and I love the
way that we sort of early on get very
much the the classic debate of these
kids today speech from everyone which is
sort of a timeless argument and I think
that's one of the main reasons that this
film still holds up like it really could
be set in any decade and still work and
because obviously the setting of a jury
room that they're very private you can't
just go in with like mobile phones and
stuff um and it's great that it can
still be relevant today the the crime
committed murder and the evidence that's
given could be could be used today and
it's just a timeless piece really and
we'll get the idea that one of them may
fold early on and that funder may start
chip away and just by the fact that he
hands over the responsibility of
delegating and and and that to me kind
of showed that he was willing to almost
bend and break two things and that's the
first real crack that we get in there
sort of guilty verdict yeah I love that
guy the actors Martin balsam the guy who
sort of coordinates all the votes and we
learned he's a football coach later on
he has this like profound calmness about
him yeah that I find quite entrancing to
watch and yeah as we go through it's
just such a fun prospect really good
structurally even the first time you
watch this film and it's 11:00 to 1:00
you know eventually it's gonna be 12 now
yeah it's just compelling to see this go
forward and you know the old man as well
the elderly man who's often shot in a
wider frame is often more the voice of
reason than Fonda really and you know
them sitting next to each other is
interesting and get so much about these
characters when they go into the
bathroom as well and I really like when
they go into the bathroom there's lots
of cool stuff that goes down there like
when we learn that the baseball guy made
like 27,000 selling marmalade it's like
in 2018 money that's crazy yeah
marmalade millionaire you know we learn
about the watchmaker and the advertisers
add fun there's an architect of course
and I like how the guy in the garage
when they're drawing hand he's like yeah
but what if you're wrong
like yeah it leads leave that
possibility all the way open yeah
and and I think it is really like that
it's one of the tenses moments because
fondest sort of comes to realization
that if he is wrong then they're letting
a man get away with murder which is the
true conflict of this film and it's it
could just be one man coming out with
his crazy conspiracy theories to
convince the others he's right and just
battering them down til they agree he's
probably a fire that
and and he's just coming out with these
conspiracy theories in everyone's that
they could potentially be letting a
murderer go because he's just sort of
beat them down with his theories and do
you think the guy did it though
maybe yeah yeah I probably do think he
actually did do it yeah uh uh it's just
for me it's just the coincidence that's
like him saying I'm gonna kill you in
someone kills you it's like okay but tie
that in with the knife and tie that in
with the movies and I've read something
online that tries to explain the movies
thing like oh yeah but in the 50s you
know yeah they showed these sort of
stuff and whatever and it's like I don't
know he could have had some sort of
element and I suppose the kind of if you
go a bit deeper societally it's saying
even if he did do it he didn't do it cuz
he was beaten from such young age that
he has an acting of his own agency and
that's kind of a deeper thing that
they're asking you and one of the thing
that I like is you have the jurors that
are really engaged like Fonda likely
Jacob we've got their own personal
grudges you get the baseball guys who
seem to literally change the vision
because they want to go to the game then
you get other people who aren't either
over really like you know they're not
too engaged over even the slum guy who
can identify with this world
doesn't seem to be seem to be mostly on
the fence and then goes one way or the
other and you get a into mob rule as
well aren't you and sort of the the
mentality this psychology of this room
how one person becomes more powerful and
yet and you gravitate towards them and
yeah I mean what about you did he do it
yeah I think he did it
and the first clue for me was when he
said that it didn't remember what movie
saw um I mean for starters there was
only about ten movies back then y'all
and I'll tell you now do not watch any
of them in 4k but I don't think they put
across a good enough argument of like
who else could have done it instead yeah
all hangs on coincidence all of these
things were just kind of happenstance
and but like there's some arguments that
like Fonda pulls out the same knife and
which shows that it's a common weapon
but I don't know this is actually goof
when they kind of do a crime
reconstruction and time it because it's
all one shot now in the film they say
it's 42 seconds but if you actually time
it Tom I didn't do this but apparently
it says on the Internet but if you
actually time it it's only 31 seconds I
think okay so the timings slightly off
on it um yeah I just I think the guy did
it and I think he's got got away with
murder and it's like we need to we need
to have explored why someone would want
to kill the father anyway like you know
yeah maybe have any enemies who would
have actually gone and killed him it's
establish maybe it's in a slightly bad
neighbor but it's hard to believe
someone would break into the house and
do it and I guess changing as well under
the old lady across the street with the
glasses and it is true that you wouldn't
sleep with your glasses but I wear
glasses and you would just put them on
and get up like yeah to look out the
street I don't think you'd look in
instinctively without them but I think
ultimately it's not really even about
the murder it's just about our
susceptibility you know they say later
you know what could of facts you can
twist and you know tie them or you like
and I just like seeing all these actors
to this great material going back and
forth and I just I love Lee Jacob the
the villain of it I think he's fantastic
I think he's I think he kind of shines
in in the piece I think he absolutely
commands I won't say stage but you know
that the camera or ever and yeah it
moves through and it has these nice
breaks in between where we get the votes
in lots of different ways
at first they verbalize them then they
write them down we could see the
handwriting and I love the shot that's
above them as they raise their hand yeah
definitely and so they do the first
count again after the first hour
surprise surprise it's two not guilty
now I love I really love Ponder's face
as he realizes like he's finally winning
it he finally realizes he's getting his
little cousin out of jail it's great and
it really highlights the acting in the
film like is all Oscar
even today it's just outstanding
performances and that moment kind of
really seals it for me and it's also
shortly after this that they when they
do the count now we get our first
close-up of the old guy and played by
Joseph Sweeney who kind of gets a raw
deal in this film like people walk out
of the room as he's talking they call
him old he gets a bit of paper thrown at
him yeah yeah I know it was one
character even coughs when he's talking
the probably egged is house you know
it's the usual way that you treat old
people but it's a great performance by
Joseph Sweeney and I really likable
character you get so many close-ups as
well like every time he talks his face
just takes up the entire screen I tell
you what Tom when you're watching it on
a 50 inch screen in 4k Tom seeing that
old guy that clothes it's not very nice
but well well not will not fall it for
it and because the it's just got a
certain charisma about him he's really
mild-mannered but he's also
authoritative um because he sort of
commands the room and he points down
people's points and he's just a great
guy he shuts down the old man's it's one
of them shuts down his views and it sort
of reveals things about his personality
there's a great speech that he does
where they're talking about the one of
the old men witnesses and the old guy
says like you probably wanted this
moment to kind of shine and because he
knew everyone would be listening to him
when he was on the witness stand and
he's probably a guy that everyone looks
down on him and hates him and doesn't
listen to what he says because he's an
old man and this is the chance to
finally have his voice heard and he
makes that amazing point and then one of
the other jurors just kind of shouts him
down like no you're stupid yeah which
does just hammer home that the old guys
right and what he was saying it's just a
beautiful moment it's really really good
yeah yeah absolutely is I think the film
uses quality you know there's a reason
why it's still crazy to me the it's
number 5 on the top 250
on IMDB it really is an anomaly on that
list like the rest of us are just sort
of pop you know great films but just big
pop-culture films really annoyed I mean
I don't think it has but I don't think
it's had that much of an influence on
popcorn didn't get reference much does
it Twyla hungry men in pretty much no I
think because like I was on the
Wikipedia and they were saying like on
The Simpsons and apparently it's
Veronica Mars against my reference and
stuff but I can't think of anything like
giant emerges apparent eats number two
courtroom drama AFI his top ten I was
number one I have to see that but I've
just got it here To Kill a Mockingbird
of course to get a few good mens also on
those
oh yeah Kramer vs Kramer the father
verdict another Sidney Lumet film
actually yeah that's a good fun with
Paul Newman but yeah as we work through
the film as well everyone growing sweaty
everyone growing more aggrieved they are
angry people you know get very het up
yeah definitely and there's just little
one-liners that there they do as well
throughout that really like it is that
one of them goes he don't even speak
good English I'd say a comedic line
especially in the 50s that's like
cutting edge and one by one we all kind
of see them change their minds and begin
to think about things more openly and in
fondest awe he's like a bit of a cult
leader he starts building this following
and it really heats up the dynamics and
you got people getting more and more
frustrated people especially they're the
main villain who he made his decision
hours ago and he's just getting he's
just sick of arguing it and shouting it
going back and forth and even though
it's all set in one room it really ramps
up and it makes it engaging which it's
hard for a lot of films that have
multiple locations to do this let alone
one that's just set in a room to keep it
constantly fresh and engaging but it
does a fantastic job and you would like
every just everything down the sweat
patches it's brilliant like I'm quite
fascinated with the crime investigation
and I watch you love document
all the time and I love how even in the
room they carry out the sort of mini
investigation they they reenact it and
they really break down the crime they
get blueprints out and it's a really
like forensic look at the crime itself
and it's then in that we have this
moment as well after it all heats up and
the villain goes I'll kill you and turns
the entire room against them yeah as
that was what one of the earlier
arguments hinged upon and things get
dark and somber and they all kind of
stand about and it gained the dynamics
change and it's just a fantastic mood
swing for the film and and it's at this
moment where they're all kind of stand
about and the rains pelting down there
just in silence that it beautifully
transitions into the third act and this
is where a lot of characters really get
a moment to shine mm-hmm yeah yeah
absolutely and we get a lot of those
swinging transitions as well like when
the guy has that horrific like when
everyone turns their back on him as well
it feels a little stage II to me I like
it don't ya probably feel to stay like
what would happen I think most of the
film does feel quite natural and that
kind of stands out as a little bit arch
a little bit exaggerated but still
enjoyable and and yeah you're right all
the characters do get their own moments
and the interplay as well between so
many of them I can't wait to see some
sort of diagram because I'm pretty sure
every character talks to every character
I'm not entirely sure but you know it's
maybe who's sitting next to who get to
have these different moments and another
guy that I really like is the
stockbroker the uptight guys one of the
last guys changes buddy the guy that
gets quizzed on the movies and talks
about the glasses as well I think he's a
really good actor and you are just
keeping point as you go through and you
know it is really a remarkable film it
was his debut Lumet's debut which is
crazy yeah it was his first film again
through first of all to be one of these
classics and yeah it's it's absolutely
sensational I think that you got
everyone to read their lines over
multiple times in the room on their own
and you know they filmed it very quickly
and it has such a naturalistic feel as
it walks out and you know the final
thing that essentially
swings it then is the eyeglasses that's
a distinct thing to catch yeah
definitely I don't think you would catch
it in real life to be honest and because
those marks I mean I wear glasses myself
and those marks that they fade after
about ten minutes and they're really
small but we'll let them off Tom and
because it is raining and it will no
it's the big fight scene because it's
raining and it's just all ramping up and
and I like how fun this sort of puts
this guy's memory in the question and
you get like a little bead of sweat
rolling down I mean I know I love the
sweat patches Tom but you got a lovely
be the sweat just rolling down his head
at this point and as he saw a break soon
realizes that yeah maybe this guy's
memory is the same as mine and because
he was quite prejudiced towards not
remembering the film as we all wear Tom
yeah but it's like he's like oh it was
the delightful miss Bainbridge is a it
was the amazing miss baby remember he
was Miss Bainbridge the break yeah
double-feature STIs like it was a little
yeah again but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna poke holes in these kind of things
I hate people poke holes in movies
anyway it's not really what it's about
but but yeah and then we get our sort of
climax I suppose it's sort of like
you've got to think if he didn't have an
emotional background the Liege acog
character with his son who it's quite a
cool background like he saw his son get
beat up and then he got broke his son e2
and then his son fought him and then you
know blah blah blah all he's sort of a
lot of classic American archetypes
father-son dynamics going down there but
it would have been nice if he was just a
neutral boys like nada
I don't think he did it I've got no
emotional reason I just don't think he
did it wouldn't made us this you know
powerful denouement as it were
yeah yeah I don't really get his motive
for white things that you did it so much
so is it just because he doesn't like
his son and he sees his son yeah I guess
it's the yeah this the the son who
fought back successfully when his son
everything cuz he says he hadn't seen
his son for years as well so yeah it's
just him in
panting himself on that Ark okay like
yes and I love what he tears with the
photo and instantly regrets it is
visceral yeah and he so it could be a
very hammy line like ripping up
something in gone not guilty yeah but he
delivers it in a really convincing way
um and it like I said it could have been
so hammy like him dropping to his knees
and writhing and paying or not guilty
because he finally breaks but yeah they
do it really well and after convincing
the jury to give a not guilty verdict
Fonda walks over to his nemesis and he
puts his coat on for me and it sort of
shows that despite the extent to which
they've argued that there's no hard
feelings they're your best mate I'm
sorry for making you rip up the picture
of your son copies back then yeah makes
it makes it even more powerful but no it
kind of it kind of makes the argument
for you know bipartisanship like you
know not being divided across these
right wrong lines like at the end of the
day we are just human as we are and I
like the fact that these have all been
jurors one to twelve and at the end
fonder in the old guy trade names I
think he's Davis he's McArdle and then
yeah then they just just walk off with
it yeah well there's actually Barr those
two names there's no names in the film
no and it's always the kid on trial or
the old man witness or the woman witness
and in the lack of names like it's
signified sort of that it's not about
the individual um it's about the group
and its ability to make good decisions
and that's what democracy is and it does
a really good job of hammering that
point home and by just excluding the
names and it's not something you realize
but even if you look up the cast list on
IMDB it's all like juror want to you're
a 2:03 and it's just a really nice study
of democracy and how you know you might
not always agree with the decision but
we're all trying to work towards a
positive thing yeah
and you know it's it's a bit more
complicated than that of course because
it is one individual who saves the day
but he's the one who understands his two
years that you remember and which is to
make sure that the group actually serves
justice yeah and I love in a classic 57
affectation at the end we get the school
playing and we just get the clothes
that's all the twelve guys and yeah it
just makes you appreciate you know how
great they all are let's just go through
quickly so juror one is the the high
school coach you know the guys or chairs
the whole thing number two is the meek
bank worker number three is the lovely J
carved the antagonist then we get the
stockbroker with the glasses we get the
slum guy who's found at the Baltimore
and the base because it's good be hidden
a crowbar everyday or something like
that the respectable house painter the
baseball guy fonder himself the old man
the this sort of a villain I guess who
eventually goes on his ran and everyone
turns their back on him the watchmaker
and then Don Draper for all effects the
ad guy who's another interesting pops
yeah yeah yeah when he's drawing that
advert Tommy turns it over I just
thought what the [ __ ] is that there's no
way anyone would ever buy that [ __ ] and
they play noughts and crosses as well
very little thing early on but um but
yeah I mean yeah that's that's twelve
Angry Men really I mean that's a film
that you know I'll always love again I
don't want to say it's not my favorite
film ever because I don't know if I
really have one maybe Toy Story you know
it's a cliche and maybe say toy store
wherever we use my throat film but yeah
I mean what did you think that something
he'd never seen it before
yeah don't quite enjoy it um it's quite
dour and downtrodden throughout but I
like that it's got a nice happy ending
and the Thunder walks away with a smile
you know he's convinced these people
they let this guy get away with murder
and he's laughing about he's the devil
that guy and that's how I interpreted it
so make sure you check out my twelve
angry man Men ending explained video
which is
so is the devil yeah it's a really
timeless piece and it's definitely still
holds up today which I don't think a lot
of films from that here I do
um and it's influenced a lot of drama
the acting especially and yeah I really
really did enjoy it I did normally when
i get i felt when i buy a film and i
don't like it i just put it on ebay
straight away but this one's still in
the blue case tom so good recommendation
no i'm glad i'm glad you enjoy it i just
just don't ind be actually Jack Klugman
who played the guy from the slums
he died on Christmas Eve 2012 normally
twelve Angry Men are alive today well he
was Quincey wasn't he
was he I think he was Quincey episode of
The Twilight Zone played like some
snooker guy in that who basically
brilliant episode of The Twilight Zone
you use a great snooker player and but
there was a guy he would come before him
who was dead and I think was called fats
but he was a fat guy yeah and he was
like you you'd never be good enough to
beat fats back in his day and anyway fat
the ghost of fats comes down and plays
them and because fat is basically been
going through eternity and people have
been challenging his ghost and fats let
him win so that he can take his place
and live forever having a challenge
everyone who's challenges he ghosts
brilliant ever so cool idea yeah but
what what are you tackling next what's
the next one I've got to tell you what a
word about this time about you taking
control of the podcasts I'm not bloody
finished and so had a couple of comments
come in and buy a couple I mean one and
from Tony madness who said twelve Angry
Men should be watched by only filmmakers
and it's use of one location instead of
basing it and sorry its use of one
location instead basing it around
character types is top level it's also
very relatable as an American as most of
us have to serve jury to UE at least
once in our lifetimes it's one of the
greatest films of all time so I thank
you very much Tony madam
doing that I am couple of tidbits as
well four-year Tom so keep these to
yourself and you already mentioned about
the director making them say that lines
are over and over without filming them
filming them and this was to give them a
real taste of what it would be like to
be cooped up in a room with the same
people and again we talked about the 41
seconds it's actually 31 seconds in the
movie on that crime reenactment and
because the film failed to make a profit
Henry Fonda never received his deferred
salary and so originally he was like no
we'll just make sure you make the film
then pay me after but it never made a
profit and but despite this setback he
always regarded it as one of his best
and he said that this was one of the
three best films that he's ever made
with the other being The Grapes of Wrath
and the Oxbow incident that you
mentioned a Grapes of Wrath that is
classic that's a good movie yeah so
anyway that's the podcast and thanks
guys for checking it out and make sure
you subscribe to the channel your non
video stuff getting no views and 12
Angry Men it's gonna get [ __ ] twelve
use like if you're over twelve use I'm
gonna be impressed it's gonna be Yard
Man wilderness and that's about it Shire
Yard Man so deaf it's always a pleasure
it's been great to be on here and I want
to urge you again on being host now I'm
sorry but we do the Watchmen podcast
Bower a resume check out deaf Channel
I'll let you close out man well you
doing a good job tom I don't want to
spoil you and basically yeah keep an eye
out for the next episode we'll be
discussing the room and the disaster
asked artists with their Adam Feldman
hey that film wash in the room guys on a
podcast called the greatest movie ever
so I'm definitely taking the name
seriously and but I'm over you anything
you want to promote yourself you already
promote with the Watchmen what about you
are there podcast what about your
Twitter tell the people follow us our
resume our resume is always there I've
been doing it for almost three years now
that's crazy I know it's [ __ ] great
we get all rep the first episode like
early 2016 or some
so yeah it's do you feel like life
wouldn't be the same if you stopped
doing it I feel like it's gone on too
long to be honest with you you know
maybe maybe I'll take a look but I'm
always gonna [ __ ] pockets I know that
for a fact I've already got two or three
pockets I want to do in the future you
know that I'm gonna start doing maybe a
little bit older
I've got like retirement podcasts that I
wanted to as well so yeah I'm always a
podcasting but yeah
Bauer resumes there and anyone has him
to Metallica as well go through every
single Metallica song in order with fans
from around the world that's always fun
it's a nice break as well it's always
like 20 30 minutes pretty quickfire I've
had loads a good guess right the guy who
produced some of their biggest Allen's
from the 8th about the father of their
legendry deceased bass player Rayburn
and so yeah if you're interested in
Metallica at all definitely check that
out what else is there really I've been
on a few other podcasts here and there
but you guys don't really care about
that but that's about me death brilliant
well thanks very much for stopping by
and it's a good note from me it's a good
night from Queen